welcome to m coding where we try to get
just a little bit better at programming
every episode so that we can have an
excuse for writing on the window with
dry erase markers i'm james murphy
available for python consulting check me
out at emcoding.io
there's one feature of python that has
not aged well so poorly in fact that
even python's creator guido von rossum
wishes that it was never added to the
language
that feature
the else clause of four and while loops
unlike if else bore else and while else
are very uncommonly used
honestly comment now if you've never
heard of these before
so first off what does this else clause
actually do
the else clause of a for a while is
triggered after the loop terminates
normally meaning without a break or
exception
so in both of these cases it'll print 0
1 2 done
whereas in either of these cases it'll
just print 0 1 and then it will not
print done
also if there are no elements to loop
over this is still considered a normal
end of the four or while loop
so the else will still be executed in
both of these cases
by now i hope that you're asking
yourself something along the lines of
okay
why is this called else
i mean if something else something makes
sense
for something else something or while
something else something what does that
really mean
and why does it correspond to this
behavior of executing if there was no
break or exception
way back in the day python was much less
popular and it was not expected to be
the only programming language that you
knew
it was basically understood that anyone
using python was already familiar with c
or c plus plus and in particular how
compilers implemented while loops in crc
plus plus
in c and c plus a while loop could just
be implemented in terms of an if check
with the same corresponding condition
and a go to statement
you label just before the start of the
loop evaluate the condition
run the body of the loop and then go
back to the start to repeat the loop so
believe it or not the else in python's
while else is actually this else in the
if go-to implementation of a while loop
if there was a break in the while loop
that would correspond to a go-to to the
corresponding end label
at the time it was expected that this
would be intuitive to users
that idea obviously didn't age that well
but like it or not in modern python that
is what it means
and likewise the else in four else was
meant for consistency with weil
alternatively you could think about it
in terms of how fours are implemented in
terms of wiles
so there's the first annoyance the
modern python programmer doesn't really
think about for and while loops in terms
of go to's python doesn't even have a go
to that's accessible to you
there was at some point some discussion
that maybe it should just be called no
break instead of else this is clearer
and more in line with what it does so
there'd be way less confusion around it
but at this point we can't really change
the else
for reasons we're about to talk about
you shouldn't really be using this
anyway but if you do choose to use the
else clause at the very least include a
comment to help jog the reader's memory
so theoretically when might you actually
be tempted to use this
the most common situation that i see is
to avoid a single extra quote-unquote
unnecessary flag variable here we have a
simple index implementation
index takes in a sequence like a list
and a target value and tells you where
in the list that value is at what index
we create a found flag to tell us
whether or not we've found the target
element then we loop over the sequence
if we find the value then we set pound
to true and break
then at the end we either raise or
return the index that we found the
element at the value of found at the end
of the loop is always equal to whether
or not we broke out of the loop
since we can detect whether we broke out
of loop using a for else we technically
don't need the found variable not found
is just when we broke out of the loop
normally so we can just use else
cleaner and simpler right
well simpler than that other
implementation but
why don't we just take this return
and put it right where the break is
then we don't need an else at all
and this is the second major reason why
for else and while else have aged so
poorly the vast majority of the time you
can get rid of a 4 else or while else
just by refactoring
take your loop that you're going to
break out of pull it out into a function
like what we have here and replace
breaks with returns
of course it's not always possible i
know you can probably come up with
something but in the vast majority of
cases it is possible
and it's the same story for the while
else
you know writing this example i actually
realized how little i actually use while
loops i pretty much always think in
terms of containers and iterables and
things that you use with for loops
okay so here's the situation besides
while true which i do use that a while
loop is actually better suited than a
for loop
i start out at some time and want to do
work for five seconds
while the current time is less than the
target time i do some work and then i
sleep for a little bit let's just
suppose that at some time there's a
possibility of some random error
occurring not an exception just some way
of detecting that an error has happened
we break out of the loop if an error
occurs and once again we use a flag to
keep track of whether or not we broke
out of the loop then we can either
handle the error or print out a done
message if we run it we see working
working working working and then after
three seconds we hit an error and handle
the error once again theoretically this
error flag is unnecessary and we can get
rid of it using a while else we do that
like this if there was no break that
means no error so we just print our done
message and return
if there was a break then we skip the
return and handle the error personally i
think this is way less readable i would
prefer to just have the error flag
all this is done in the name of
performance but this is going to be a
huge readability cost for what extra
performance really saving one extra
boolean the performance benefit is going
to be minuscule at best if you can even
measure it the only time something like
this could make a difference is if you
were doing it inside of a hot loop and
even then the savings are still going to
be less than a percent so please join me
in actively avoiding for else and while
else personally i rarely see four else
actually used and i have not once ever
seen while else used in production code
although even the creator of python
thinks that it was a bad idea that it
was ever put into the language in the
first place it's probably never going to
be removed that would be a major
backwards incompatibility requiring a
python 4-0 release
from the python 2 to python 3 transition
the python community already learned how
much of a hassle this is so in the
future it's unlikely that it'll get
removed but there are still some things
that i would recommend for you
of course stop using it and tell your
friends and coworkers to stop using it
and politely suggest your devops or
python infrastructure team to either
turn on or create a linter rule to
prevent you from doing this
if you'd like to hear more about
creating your own lender rules check out
my video on the topic and finally i just
want to say that all this bad stuff
about elsa's is only for for else and
while else
i have nothing against if else or try
except else in fact i think try except
else is actually very underutilized
anyway and as always thank you for
watching don't forget to like the video
comment and subscribe for more python
content special thanks to my patrons and
donors for supporting me i really
appreciate the support if you especially
like my content please consider becoming
a patron or donor